um i remind those of you new to my uh
channel what is a study
a study or a composition is a position
that was invented as you can imagine a
position that was invented by somebody
not from an actual over-the-board game
and
in studies first of all it's always
white to play so you always look at it
from white's point of view that's just
convention
and studies can come in two types there
could be ones that require you to make a
draw with best play and then there are
studies where you have to win so with
best play
by both you and your opponent
white wins
[Music]
why what is even the like point of
studies well studies are supposed to be
beautiful so
really good studies feature themes and
patterns and variations
that rarely occur in in over-the-board
chess be and
the best studies are tremendously
beautiful there's many many different
kinds of themes many kinds of studies
but the point is that the line the
solution in a study has to be somewhat
forced it doesn't have to be literally
forced but it has to be solvable by a
human like it can't just be a random
position
like that the main line has to be
relatively clear
so in this study by a guy named matus it
was a famous composer this was composed
around the 1970s i think it is white to
play and win with best play white wins
the game
with best play
okay
so
let's figure out what's going on here
white's pawns are going this way first
of all white is down two pawns
and
just looking at the position
you might see that white has a couple of
tempting checks white also can capture
black's knight so let's start with this
move what just happens if black white
captures black's knight
um
you might notice here that uh if black
simply recaptures the pawn remember that
queen and bishop versus queen even with
no pawns is a draw in most cases
but here white has bishop e7 chuck and
because of the pin the king has to move
and loses the queen but the problem is
that black can actually give a check on
e6
driving the king out
and then take on g6 with check and this
is this is just a draw black has three
pawns for the piece and the king is not
going to be able to evade perpetual
check and even if it does
black doesn't even need to give a check
you can just move the king up to g7
so
that doesn't work
you could also try g takes h7 it might
say oh well
the king is not able to stop the pawn
unfortunately the bishop is hanging with
check
and here black is actually winning
so that doesn't work either
a third tempting move is queen to d6
check
and this is what most people think the
solution is initially
well if g takes f7 then queen takes f7
and black is okay
g takes h7 looks like it checkmates
because after king takes h7 white has a
very pretty
mating sequence who sees it
and who sees the flaw in this why is
this not winning by force
yeah queen d6 is wrong
yeah if you look at the whole board
you'll see the queen drops back to h2
then up to g3
then mates on g7 nothing spectacular but
it's winning
unfortunately the king can hide behind
the pawn in h8 white is out of checks
and black is threatening to trade queens
and make a draw with queen e6 check
there is just no and this is computer
check there's no way to win here
if steven's 11 thing
so neither of those moves work
the correct move is not a check and it
is not a capture
but
clearly by process of elimination the
correct move has to defend the bishop
and it has to defend the e6 square
or or maybe not but at the very least it
has to defend the bishop well if g7 and
king g8 and again
the checks are extinguished so the
correct move frost got it queen c8
not only does this defend the bishop it
also threatens bishop to e7 check which
as we already know wins the queen
now what about queen e6 check you might
ask doesn't this trade queens and make a
draw we'll know this position white
takes on h7
and on the next move white promotes with
me
because the knight blacks knight is what
kills him here
okay well does black have any defense to
bishop e7 check
does anybody see black's defense and
part of study solving involves finding
the best defense that's called the
counter play
in studies it's not enough to just
solve it from the winning side you have
to
fully understand how the opponent is
going to react most resiliently king g8
the king escapes
the king escapes the check on e7
okay
now comes the amazing part of the style
so we need to figure out what to do here
again g takes h7 as we already know
doesn't lead anywhere up due to kha
g takes f7 also queen takes f7 that's
check
so here is where you really have to
think outside the box and find a
beautiful idea
um
it's not that there's no logic to the
correct move but it is really really
hard to spot this idea if you're not an
experienced study solver
so when you are stumped and you're in
the critical position one question that
you can often ask yourself is well what
moves am i ruling out just because they
look ridiculous like what
category of moves
am i not even considering
um
and then to take a look at those various
moves
well that category is probably moving
the bishop right you're probably not
thinking about moving the bishop because
it blunders the queen why would we do
that
and
it doesn't seem like it could possibly
be checkmate because the king always has
h8 as a retreating square
yeah but young chess kind of got it
um well a lot of you are suggesting king
g5 i don't get this move folks because
black can just take the fun you're not
creating any threats
so let's consider a random bishop move
let's consider bishop takes a5 for a
second let's think about that for just a
second
well after queen takes c8 g takes f7
check you might notice something really
interesting
you might say wait a second if the king
goes to f8 we actually deliver checkmate
on b4
the king has to go to h8
and that king is awfully boxed in
and it would be very nice if we have
this retreat back to c3 which would
threaten a discovered mate against the
king the queen
seems to be stuck to the f8 square if
the queen moves anywhere we promote with
checkmate
well what's the problem with this
specific
with this specific execution
what's the problem with this specific
execution
it's checked the queen takes the bishop
of check but part of study solving
involves spotting the right idea and
then modifying it to suit your needs
so maybe we don't need to take the pawn
maybe we need to bring the bishop
somewhere such that he can land on this
diagonal without being threatened by
black queen so let's consider bishop c7
well if knight takes c7 then there's g
takes f7 check winning the game
so black has to go down this path takes
gf by the way bishop b6
doesn't work because after queen takes
c8 gf black has king f8 and the c5
square is unfortunately covered so
bishop c7 is really the only way to get
the bishop onto that diagonal
king h8 bishop b5
and if you adjust yourself adjust your
eyes to this position you'll actually
see that it seems like there is no
defense
to the threat of the king stepping aside
with checkmate
if the h pawn moves to get the h7 square
to get some luft the king steps into g6
with me
but black does have a defense
black does have a defense
while queen c6 trick doesn't help you
just move the king away
queen c5 akilah got it queen c5 is the
only move
now you might say wait a second we just
moved the king with mate how does this
help and if the queen takes the bishop
you promote with checkmate
unfortunately the queen takes the bishop
with check
giving black enough time to squeeze the
king into f8 and block the pawn black
wins here
this happens no matter where you bring
your king if you bring it to g5 it's
also check
you might say ah let me promote first
and distract the queen and then step
aside to checkmate but here there's
another problem you've given away the
pawn and now the king has g8
also queen g7 is possible
so what do we need to do here well we
have only one remaining approach if we
can't promote him we can't move our king
we have to move our bishop
in order to renew the threat
of king stepping away to e6 with me
we can't move it here we can't move it
here let's say we bring it to
b2 let's say we bring it to b2
or let's say we bring it all the way
back to a1 let's try to be as safe as
possible
now again we're threatening king e6
checkmate
and that's the only square that the king
can possibly step aside to so what is
black's defense here
again i think you guys are thinking
about black's defense in the wrong way
giving the king a check doesn't help it
actually helps the king get to where it
wants to go you have to cover the square
that the king is threatening to go to
and you can do that by involving the
knight to c7 and it looks like white's
in big trouble
because the king now doesn't have a
single square can go to white is stuck
and this is where in my eyes the real
beauty of the study comes in
bishop a1 is not the right move by the
way but we'll get to the rainbow
and this is something you just kind of
have to realize
let's say for a second that it's black
to play let's pass the move to black
let's make a random bishop of bishop b2
does black have a single way to preserve
the net against the king
well we know that if the knight moves
the king will have e6 that's why we
brought it to c7 and after knight c3 we
already know that bishop c3 is made
so the knight can't move
can the queen move
no it can't if it gives a check on d6
the king sf5 wherever the queen goes
white has either promotion or a king
move with me
if the age pawn moves again we're
already familiar with the mating idea
king g6
this means that black has only one
possible
piece that black can move queen f8
also gets mated with king f5 queen g7
and f8 queen
if queen c6 then
anything mates king e7
if queen f2
then again king e7 is made
you have to remember that not only does
the queen have to stop all of the king
moves but if the queen takes its eyes
off of f8 this is going to be mate
okay so hopefully that's clear
black has to play a4
but black can run at a pawn move so what
should white try to do here white should
try to get this pawn
to exhaust itself and then to take it
with the bishop and then that's going to
lead to zuma but then there's now
another problem
the bishop doesn't have too many squares
down this diagonal it has to go back to
a1
and unfortunately after a3 it's white
who's in zugsvan and not black we have
to give up our bishop we lose
but in studies you have to do this
problem solving again we spotted the
right idea
but somewhere along the line our
execution was incorrect now where was
the execution and correct when did we
have a choice
yeah problem got it
we played bishop a1 because it looked
safer
but now we realize that we have to go
bishop b2 to get the move order right
knight c7
bishop a1 a4
bishop b2 a3 and by contrast it's black
to move in this position a2 is forced we
go bishop b2
black has to promote we take it black is
in zugsvan and loses the game
amazing amazing position
and that's what makes all of the
difference
who creates such puzzles matus i mean
there are composers who create these
kinds of puzzles they are geniuses in
their own right this guy was in a strong
chess player composers aren't
necessarily very strong players i mean
he's probably 17 1800 he died a couple
of years ago
yeah this is a world most people are
completely unaware exist there are
probably thousands of studies like this
you know of this beauty
and not all studies are this beautiful
obviously there's many of bad studies
there are studies that are flawed
but nowadays studies composed
recently are always computer checked so
they're not going to be published unless
they are correct
um and studies have a very strict
solving
um standard so if if a study has an
alternate solution the solution is
called a cook
you say that the study is cooked
and that means it's a it's a bad study
like you are not allowed to have
multiple solutions
to a study it has to have one and only
one solution at every critical move
um
so let me go through this one more time
you start with queen c8 to threaten
bishop e7 you force the gain to g8 now
you sacrifice the queen in order to get
the bishop to this diagonal and threaten
me
the next stage is black trying to cover
all of the
king retreats which would open up a
discovered check
knight c7
and now we force zugswang by moving the
bishop back and forth forcing the a pawn
to give itself up
um
i'll give you guys one resource before i
go
on the topic of study solving there's a
website arbs.org arves.org
which is kind of like a
you know the premier
website for studies and
you can sort of browse
it has a bunch of like biographies of
study composers and for every composer
it basically has their top studies
that's a good place to start and i'll
think about that question more and maybe
share other resources in future streams
but
a-r-v-e-s-arbs.org i don't know how to
properly say it but
that's the bottom line all right guys i
gotta run i gotta make a dinner so
i'm going to cut it off here but i hope
you enjoyed the study
i hope you enjoyed the study and um
i'll definitely do more
in the future i think this is kind of a
hit
really appreciate it have a great rest
of your evening i'll probably stream
tomorrow as well
[Music]